Beautiful, all right, Ryan Dalton.
So guys, real quick before we get into this call, which by the way, we're gonna be talking
about 2025.
We're gonna be talking about how to, I called this stream, this live is how to gear up for
the best year of your life.
And I wanted to have, you know, I mean, arguably, not arguably, I think hands down out of anybody
in this, not even, I think, I know, hands down without a doubt, 2024 was your year,
man.
Yeah, 2024 was a great year.
Yeah, I mean, 2023 had a great year, but 2024, you did some incredible things, which we're
gonna get into.
But real quick, I just wanted to make one quick announcement.
By the way, Jahil, what's going on?
One quick announcement, guys, is we talked about this, I kind of alluded to this, I think
it was last week, but we are constantly, you know, listening to feedback from you guys
on Rankin' Ren Engine as you guys, if any of you guys have no idea what we're talking
about, rankinrenengine.com, that's the only tool you need for this business.
We listen to the feedback.
My team gives it to Ryan, and I know that you guys are giving it and we're listening.
Obviously, there's people in other countries that those are things that we're gonna be
rolling out.
But one of the, I think, only things that was left on the tool was the backlinking piece.
And the nice part is it still, you know, when you do the due diligence on Rankin' Ren Engine,
you can still see the backlinks, it still gives you data.
When Ryan and I discussed, I'm like, if we could go a little deeper to have something
similar to like a man ghouls, where we could not just see the backlinks so we could look
at the backlink profile, see the referring domains, I think this thing would be the most
complete tool out there for Rankin' Ren.
So Ryan, can you give us some kind of update in terms of that, I know you told me, but
just for everybody else, when we can expect kind of that rollout, a conservative estimate
on when we can expect that feature to be added?
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, so I think in the next conservatively, in the next 30 days, we got the holidays coming
up.
So that's gonna make things a little bit slower than normal.
But all the data is there, actually.
So we have all the data to create that.
Right now, we're just making everything look real pretty on the front end so that when
you actually use that part of the tool, it looks pretty, which I'm a big believer in.
So we'll have that rollout pretty soon.
And people want to be able to do copycat backlinks and know where they're comparing backlinks
and all that.
So that's an easy addition.
Beautiful.
And by the way, there's going to be a few people because I do see some people that have
joined in the last week, copycat backlinking.
Well, let me just even go a little bit deeper and go very basic.
Backlinking is, I would call it, kind of like a steroid to get your website ranked.
If, you know, there are times when you don't have to backlink.
If you go into a very, very easy city and niche, you do really good content, you do
everything else very sound, I have ranked websites without any backlinks.
But when your website gets stuck on page two, bottom of page one, or you just want to speed
things up, backlinking is a steroid.
It is a way to get the website kind of out of that rut and get it to the top of page
one.
But essentially, maybe, I know this is very basic for some people, but maybe, Ryan, in
30 seconds, for those that there's a few people I know that are brand new to online, to SEO,
what is backlinking?
Just so everybody knows what the heck we're talking about.
It's not that complicated, but it sounds complicated.
Yeah, a backlink is any time that your website is referenced somewhere else on the internet,
basically, and Google will rank based on what they call their EAT, acronym, expertise,
authoritativeness, and trustliness.
And one of the things they look for is all these different signals to see if your website
meets their standard for ranking, right?
Ultimately, they're trying to decide, is the website, are the websites that they're returning
the search results answering the searcher's question?
And the websites that have the highest expertise, authoritativeness, and trustworthiness
are going to answer the question better than ones that don't.
So to find that, they look at all these different signals.
And one of the key ones, one of the most important ones is backlinks, which are basically
just a popular contest.
It's other websites saying your website answers those questions about whatever that is, like
a keyword, like concrete contractor, right?
Other websites are talking about you as the concrete contractor and pointing to your URL
from their website.
That signals to Google, hey, this guy probably knows what he's doing with concrete.
And then you rank higher than your competitors.
That's it.
Remember that, guys, the popularity contest.
It's just like, I always think about like high school or your friends or whatever.
It's like who you hang around is who people assume you are, right?
So the way that you hang around people on the internet is people refer to you.
People send you a backlink.
And so, for example, let's just say, and it's kind of like a status thing, like Forbes.
Forbes would have more status than any mommy blog or construction blog or whatever.
So if Forbes gave me a backlink, they're telling Google, hey, Google, I have a lot
of status.
And this website, BentonvilleConcrete.com, I'm basically giving them my approval.
And so then Google's looking at it going, OK, well, if Forbes says that, then they must
have some status.
And so it's basically this game of just getting people to link to you.
And there are strategies.
But one of the most common is called the copycat method.
All it is is looking at other people that are winning, other people that are ranking,
finding where they're getting backlinks, and just going and copycatting and doing the exact
same.
And so what we're saying to wrap all this up is this tool is going to allow you to go
find those links and to be able to go and harvest them yourself.
So it sounds like a lot.
When I first got started, again, let's remember, I didn't know how to build a website.
I didn't know what a domain was.
And here we are talking about backlinks.
It's not that complicated.
So Gina says, I've been on a mission to figure out and set up backlinks for our sites.
I'm still trying to figure it out.
Yeah, it's really not that difficult.
So what we'll do, maybe when we roll that feature out officially, we'll go and do a
backlink training, just some basic one-on-one how to do backlinks.
But yeah, guys, if you haven't already, you can use any tool you want.
I know when I started, I was using a combination of seven different tools.
I had all kinds of different stuff that we had opened up.
I had even had a custom software built to track my paper lead stuff when I was doing
that, which I don't recommend.
But if you want to make it easy, go to RankinRentEngine.com, sign up for an account.
It's ridiculously affordable.
And we also have a code that...
Ryan, for anybody that hasn't already, let's just write that code in the chat real quick.
That's the one.
And that's 20% off for the first two months.
Yeah, I think I've got a bunch of codes.
I think that's the one that has that one.
So I can confirm that after the call.
But yeah, I think it's 20% off for two months.
Beautiful.
So guys, go check it out.
It's the only tool that we're using.
It makes due diligence so much faster.
Anyway, there's a million different things.
That's not what this call is about.
But just wanted to give a quick little plug for that and know that the backlinkings coming out.
So move your stuff over.
You can buy your phone.
How much are your phone numbers through RankinRentEngine?
Yeah, it depends on how you do it.
So you could get additional, add additional sites.
And if you add additional sites, the number comes free with it.
Otherwise, they're $2.50 a month.
Which is half the price.
$2.50, right?
Yeah.
And I think on CallRail, even if you do...
Even me, I've got a bunch of numbers because I'm moving my stuff over still.
I think the cheapest I ever got them was like five bucks a number.
I could be wrong.
But that's very, very cheap.
One of the things I realized about some of these other platforms is that they're
like, they've got like different tiers that are kind of confusing versus like your
programmable voice is add-on, your CRM is add-on.
Look at some of these other competitors.
And it just signals to me that it's just not made for RankinRent.
It's made for like different marketing strategies or tools or whatever you're trying to do.
But for RankinRent, it needs to be just pretty straightforward.
Like you have to have programmable voice and messaging.
So it's baked right in.
Yep, yep.
No, it's slick, man.
It's super simple.
So, okay, guys, that said, real quick, Jahil says, Ryan, quick question.
I don't know if this is already in the works, but if it's possible,
will there be a tracker in Rare that shows how many keywords someone here,
someone has remaining for the day?
Kind of similar to Mangools.
Let me shut my door.
Totally.
Yeah.
So that exists now.
So if in the top right, you click on your profile and then you click on the usage tab,
you can see daily keyword lookups remaining.
And so your plan will determine how many that number is.
But you can go in there and you can see for today how many lookups remain.
You can also see your site lookups remaining.
And those are really just basically API limitations
to not spam the API at the end of the day for looking those up.
But you can look at all your usage statuses under your profile on the usage tab.
There you go.
Hopefully that answered your question, Mr. Jahil.
So let's get into this call, guys.
It's December 17th.
We have literally like two weeks to the day, like two weeks in a day, right?
Yeah.
It's almost over, man.
Quarter four is almost done.
That's crazy.
I say this every year, dude.
But it's like it feels like I just set my goals for 2024.
Yeah.
And here we freaking are.
Okay.
So let's talk about it, dude.
I want to...
So in 2024, Ryan, where were you at when 2024 started in terms of revenue?
I will tell you right now.
So January is a little bit weird because I did like trial or like discount rates for people,
like in some areas in the winter.
But I started...
Yeah.
So I came in at 2024 around $37,000 a month.
Okay.
Yeah.
$38,000.
I'm looking at my spreadsheet right now.
$38,000 at the start of 2024.
Okay.
$37,000, $38,000 started 2024.
And so, guys, let's keep in mind, Ryan, still...
Up until, was it like a week and a half or two weeks ago, you had a full-time job?
Still do.
Through the 31st or the 50th year.
I'm still got it.
I'm done.
Yeah.
He's done after this.
Two more weeks, but he's done.
So he has a full-time job, which I still can't comprehend.
He's got kids.
He's got a wife.
And he also does jujitsu.
He's got a dog.
He throws parties at his house.
Not ragers, but like he brings his friends over.
Like he has a million things going on, right?
I'm sure you have a Christmas party because I know you do a 4th of July party.
Yeah.
So my friend group has, like everyone kind of does one of the parties.
Mine are the summer ones.
I've got Memorial Day, July 4th, and Labor Day.
So they're the best ones.
They're the best ones.
Let's be honest.
Yeah, for sure.
So, okay, so let's just think about this.
So in the last 11 and a half months, you've added $50,000 of revenue per month, right?
So you're around, what are you at, 87, 88?
Yeah, I'm at when I've got a couple of people, their own discount rates,
but when they come off of those, I'll be at 89.5.
Okay.
I'm just, you just gave me a thought.
So I want to write it down.
89.5.
So I added $50,000 of revenue while having a full-time job.
And the most impressive part is on top of that, you also built rank and run engine.
Yeah.
Which, of course, he hired developers, but he was very tightly project managing that entire thing.
And so as I sat here and I'm thinking about New Year's, or the New Year,
I'm thinking about 2025.
I'm thinking about all these things I want to accomplish.
I'm like, what better person to have on than the person that had the best year out of anybody,
not only in my group, but in the free group, not only in this group, but in the free group,
but of, I would say any of the people that I know.
So I want to talk about that, dude.
I want to know, let's reverse engineer.
What did you do that made such a difference from the year before,
which you had a phenomenal year the year before?
And guys, for those that are new, like some of you guys that are, reach your first call.
Ryan, two, was it about two years ago?
When did you start this?
I'm going into my third year.
That's crazy.
Two years ago, I didn't know what this was.
Yeah, so 2022 February was the first time that I turned on a Google ad.
I'm not crazy.
It's wild.
And it's inspiring because that's the possibilities of what's possible.
So two years ago, he didn't even know what this was.
Now he's at $87,000, $89,000 a month, built a tool that's phenomenal for this space.
I think it's the best tool out there already.
It's going to be hands down the best tool once he had a few more features
and done all this while having a family, while having a job.
And I just want to know, dude.
So I basically with this, I just want to, what did you do?
How did you start the year?
How did you gear up for 2025?
What was your mindset?
What was your planning?
What was your, did you get rid of a bunch of unnecessary things?
How did you manage all of this?
So I mean, that was like five questions, but we could start with one of them.
So let's get down.
I love the mindset stuff, man.
Like the mindset, I know some people think it's cheesy and they're like,
oh, I'll talk about mindset again.
But I am a, I'm just a huge believer in this business model.
And it doesn't, I was telling my wife this other day, it doesn't feel like work to me.
Like that's, I think one of the biggest differences, like people like, oh, like,
you know, you're up at nine o'clock at night, like working on something.
It doesn't feel like work.
It feels like play to me.
Like when I'm figuring out how to grow, how to expand, how to do the next thing,
it doesn't feel like work.
And I have like pretty good work-life balance.
So I'm not always trying to like, you know, be in front of a computer,
but when I am in front of a computer, it feels like something I really enjoy.
And the other part of it is, is that I think the AI is going to change our future
quite drastically.
And I think that the trades, the services that we help enable
through the lead that we provide are not going anywhere.
And my guess is they're probably going to be the last to be impacted.
Like, how are you going to have a robot put in a concrete driveway?
You know what I'm saying?
So like, I am thinking way forward because I work in tech, you know,
I've worked in tech for years and I know that there's a lot of jobs
that are just like all coming on the chopping block.
But I don't think that the trades are anywhere near in jeopardy of that.
Like think about it, right?
Like you're going to have a brick mason that's going to be replaced by a robot.
No, or a concrete guy, or none of the trades, the roofer or whatever,
are going to be, I think, in the near term impacted by AI.
And so I'm trying to align myself and my company and my finances
and my vision for things that are enduring and lead generation for tradespeople
is, I think, a really, really safe, safe move.
And so I want to grow a business that is future proofed.
Yeah.
So, and that's one of the things when I started this business,
there was a lot of different factors that were, you know, important to me,
scalability, recurring, all those different things.
But I didn't even really consider that piece or the piece that
this is a pretty recession resistant industry, right?
Obviously, we've all probably talked to our business owners,
like I had a business owner during the elections,
and right before that, he kind of got a little shaky on me.
I don't know if people are still buying, and by the way, he's still with us.
Now that the elections are over, I think it was all in his head.
Now he's like, people are finally starting to buy again.
Maybe not, but he's good now.
But outside of that, dude, we really didn't have,
like I don't think we had any cancellations, nothing that was directly tied to that.
But I didn't think about the fact that this is very recession resistant,
a business, a very recession resistant business.
And I've also a very, it has a lot of longevity because it's just a very,
guys, I think you probably realize this too, Ryan,
but like the more I'm in business and just in life in general,
the more I'm attracted to stuff that's simple, right?
Simple scales, simple is sexy.
It's like all these complex things I don't want anything to do with.
And this is such a simple business model that it just makes sense.
So going back to the mindset stuff, is there anything that you can give us?
Like, what do you do?
How did you prepare and how did that have to do with your year in 2024?
And what advice would you give anyone that's on this call
for how to get their mind right going into 2025?
Yeah, so I agree with you about the simple stuff.
I just, I got the chat over here on the left.
I think Tim asked a question about AI chat bots.
And this kind of goes with my answer to this question is that
I think that there are a lot of ways to try to improve your agency
that feel like you're improving your agency, but you're just getting distracted.
So what I try to avoid is things that are going to become a problem at scale.
And so that means, you know, like if there's some plugin that looks cool,
or if there's some AI chat bot, or if there's, you know,
whatever there is the thing that people are testing out
and kind of the SEO world or whatever.
Generally, I found those are distractions is that rarely do I find something
that is so valuable, I will bake it into my agency from the top to bottom.
And I will, if I'm not careful, I'm prone to this.
I'm super prone to this.
I will catch myself testing lots of different little things that are just time sucks,
that are creating complexity in my agency instead of simplicity.
Like I'm always thinking about how to make it simpler, actually.
So if I'm putting my time into something, it's not adding complexity.
It's reducing it in some areas, whether that's, you know,
automations or like tying things together with like the finance stuff on the back end
or those kinds of things, making it simpler rather than more complex.
And sometimes maybe AI chat bots will actually make it simpler for you
because you're able to get leads to a business owner
in a way that is actually more streamlined, valid.
But I'm always trying to think about how to simplify.
Even at my current run rate, I'm thinking about how to make my agency simpler
and just smoother in its operations.
Yeah. Yeah, and it's also, I feel like when you first start out,
it's always about addition and how, what do I need to add?
What do I need to start doing?
And then you realize it's more about what, it's about subtraction.
What in this next year can I get rid of in my business
and in my processes and my systems in my life
so I can just focus on one single thing?
And so that was a huge thing for me when I had my biggest year in terms of like growth
when 2020 from 8 to 10,000 up to 100,000, that was a year of simplicity.
And it was getting rid of a lot of distractions,
getting rid of a lot of little micro businesses inside the business,
selling the SEO, selling this service, that service, consulting,
focusing on a bunch of different niches,
trying a bunch of different strategies to onboard customers.
And it was just, I was just cutting stuff, cutting stuff, cutting stuff.
And I would just wake up, same thing.
Get a new area, two areas, put up some ads, go do a deal.
And that was it, man.
And that's how I scaled.
And it was so easy.
It wasn't easy.
It was just mentally, I had a lot of clarity.
So for you mindset-wise, are there, are you somebody that does like,
what do you do for that?
Is it reading?
Is it talking to certain people?
Is it listening to certain things?
Like, what do you do to gear up that way?
Yeah, it's, I read a lot.
I got this book.
It's called Blitz Scaling.
Have you read this?
I've never even heard of that book.
It looks interesting.
It's the founder of, the co-founder of LinkedIn.
He's a partner at a firm called Greylock Partners.
Yeah, Greylock's is venture capital, right?
And the tagline is the lightning fast path to building massively valuable companies.
Interesting.
And I was like, I can't read this.
That I got to read that.
So I'm reading it.
Like one of his big ideas is that you have to, well, you don't have to,
but he talks about growing to optimize for speed,
which you talk about all the time over efficiency.
And the idea is, is you'll figure out the efficiency later.
And so my inclination is towards efficiency,
where I want to have everything like buttoned up, like as I grow.
And so it means my growth is kind of like this.
Whereas if you focus on speed, you'll figure out the inefficiencies later on.
You'll figure out like the, which is more your style, right?
Which is more like you'll grow and then like you'll figure out the pieces
that you got to figure out to make it real smooth.
And so this book has really challenged my mindset.
So I like to read.
I like to read stuff.
Okay. By the way, is that Reid Hoffman?
Yeah. Reid Hoffman and Chris Yeh are the co-authors.
Interesting guy. I like that guy.
It's a good read.
So give us three recommended books for mindset going into this year.
And guys, again, also just as for the person that's going to go and be like,
well, I'm going to go read for eight hours today,
because that's what Warren Buffett does.
No, that's just things to read.
I'm sure Ryan probably reads 10 pages to 30 minutes a day.
He probably doesn't sit and read for three hours.
So let's not go too extreme here.
But anyway, give us three recommended books on mindset that have really helped you.
Three books on mindset that helped me.
The three that come to mind are
Humilitas.
The theory behind Humilitas is the big idea with each book.
And you can decide if you're interested.
Humilitas is the idea that one of the missing things for success in life
is the combination of steely grit and humility.
Those two things are like what drives some of the most successful people in the world.
Great book.
Another is Meditations by Marcus Aurelius.
You can see where my shoulder.
See that guy right there?
See the bust of the dude behind me?
Is that Meditations?
Yeah, boy.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, dude.
That's the good stuff.
You got it on your desk.
All right.
Yeah, man.
Meditations is the big idea.
It's the Stoic principles.
It's a little bit, it's philosophy, but the ideas in it are really good for business.
I went through Y Combinator.
And one of the things that Y Combinator said when they look for a founder
is they want someone who a bomb can go off.
And they just look at it.
And they're like, huh, a bomb went off.
And they go back to solving problems.
Like whatever the problems that bomb caused.
Like the James Bond kind of idea, right?
Meditations is the operating system for the mind, right?
Your brain, like a computer, needs an operating system.
And if you don't have an operating system,
it means that you're just sort of a kind of a mess, right?
So having a deliberately created operating system for your brain
is the purpose of philosophy.
And Meditations is great for business
because there are no shortage of problems in business.
For example, if I've got a business owner
who I'm killing it for, and I'm getting 80 liens a month,
and he calls me and he cancels
because he is getting tons of commercial job
that I helped him get, right?
I helped him get all that commercial work
and now he's not interested in my 80% residential leads, right?
He's canceling on me.
That is completely outside of my control.
I have no control over that.
And so when I get upset about it, no, right?
I shouldn't anyway, right?
It's out of my control.
Why should I get upset about it?
That's one of the big concepts in Meditations
is it teaches your brain to be like,
oh, this problem happened.
Huh, okay, I'm gonna go solve it, right?
It's really good.
And then the third one was
Never Split the Difference by Chris Voss.
The art of negotiation, persuasion, empathy, and active listening.
All three great for business.
Beautiful.
So I've linked up two.
I'm gonna link up this last one
so everyone can have an easy way.
By the way, there is no affiliate here.
I just went to Amazon to type these in.
I wish there was an affiliate for books.
I need a bigger audience to get an affiliate for.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
It would be nice.
So those are the three that Ryan recommends, guys.
Humilitas, Meditations, and Never Split the Difference.
I've never even heard of the first one.
I've heard of the other two, obviously, but that's awesome.
Okay, so now tell us like, how did you set your,
what was your goal setting that process like about a year ago?
I guess it would have been December 2023
as you're gearing up for 2024.
What was that like, dude?
Yeah, this is an area that I am not very good at actually,
and I need to do it for this year.
I'm really good at committing today to what I need is required
and what will take to move the needle today.
Like that's my strength.
My weakness is I'm not good at setting a goal
and backward planning with key performance indicators.
I do this in my job, or I did in my job.
I don't know why I didn't do it in my agency.
It's weird, like a mental thing.
So I wouldn't say that I sat down in December of last year
and like planned out this year.
The thing that I did in December though,
is I realized I had like pretty significant chunk of time
under my belt of like really knowing
how to do this business model.
And then realizing that going into next year,
I need to be aggressive.
And I invested, I reinvested back into my agency
a significant amount of money
that I could have taken as profit,
that I just dumped back in.
And I attribute a lot of that to my growth.
So when you started the year, you didn't have in mind,
hey, I want to hit this revenue number or anything like that?
No, that's what's easy.
Bad at that kind of thing.
It's an air of opportunity for me for sure.
That's crazy, bro.
So you didn't have any idea,
in the back of your mind, did you say, hey,
like obviously you didn't sit down and write it down,
but in the back of your mind, did you sit down and think,
I want to hit this revenue target?
Well, you had me on a call with two others a while back
and we all joked about who's going to be the first to get to 83.
And I said, I'm going to be the first.
And so I knew in my brain, I never forgot that.
And I was like, I don't know if I was the first.
I don't know if those, I hope both of them did it.
Both those guys are all small.
Both those guys, I hope they both did it.
I have no idea where their agencies are.
But I was like, even if it's not a competition, I'm going to do it.
And so I think in some ways, that was my goal for this year
is to get to the million recurring.
So just for anyone that hasn't been on any of these calls with Ryan.
So Ryan has already made a million dollars.
This has been months ago, total, since he started.
But now he's on the run rate to make a million dollars per year.
Which again is crazy because you literally just decided
to start researching business models.
And it's not like anything goes wrong with your job.
It's not like you don't like your job.
It's not like you aren't getting paid very well.
You just saw the writing on the wall and you're like, dude,
I don't want to be in a position of someone else controlling my future
or controlling my paycheck.
And so it's crazy, bro.
It's a crazy...
How many months of research did you do before you actually found this model?
About three.
I started in like, probably the end of 2021,
just getting up in the morning and just reading about different business models.
Like I knew I was going to commit to one going into the next year,
where all year, full year, I was going to commit to one and not look back.
And if I failed, I knew I gave it a real shot.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I really gave a real shot at it.
That's the only way that you can know if something works or not.
You can't flirt with it.
You can't try it a little bit.
You got to go for it.
And so I wanted to make sure that the decision I made
about the industry or business model or whatever that I went into
was informed as much by my goals as possible.
And it turned out all right.
Yeah, I'd say it turned out all right, man.
Yeah.
That's insane.
It's exciting even for me.
By the way, Adair said he just closed a business owner just now for $800 a month.
He'll have to watch the replay.
So you got to love that.
Love that.
Got to love that.
That's okay.
Go ahead.
Fires me up.
I love closed deals.
Me too.
I love that because...
And by the way, guys, if you ever have to come down to
getting on this call or doing that, that is what you should be doing.
So if you have to schedule a call, just schedule the call.
Go close the deal.
You can watch the replay.
We do love having you on here if you don't have that going on.
But that's what this business model is about.
And going back to the simplicity thing,
the way you're going to make the most amount of money,
the most amount of progress in 2025, guys,
is by focusing on how can you ask the most amount of people for money.
Absolutely.
As much as you need to learn the basics,
you need to learn the back linking,
you need to learn the content,
you need to learn how to build sites,
you need to focus on how to get business owners to pay you.
That's it.
I learned that from you, man.
That was something that I can hear your voice in my head sometimes
when I think about that.
I think that is just great business advice is
the more that you can ask people for money,
the faster your agency is going to grow.
That's one of the big things I learned in digital landlords is,
and your calls and you talking about that concept,
and my goal became one closing call a week.
I have to have one closing call a week.
If there's not a closing call in a week, I'm upset.
It's not someone else's fault.
It's my fault.
But I have to have a closing call every week.
And now I'm trying to get to where I want two closing calls per week.
We've had as many as six in a week.
That's an outlier.
That's by far the exception.
But it's based on that principle that I learned in digital landlords is
you just have to be asking people for money
because if you're not, it's a hobby.
Yeah.
And people don't want to hear that.
Especially people in other groups.
Sometimes maybe I'll go and do a call with people in other groups.
And I'll always ask how many people are making money and whatever.
We'll raise our hand.
I'm like, well, the rest of you guys just have a hobby.
And it really makes people uncomfortable.
But it's the truth.
But yeah, I mean, to speak on that really, really quick, guys.
For me, the thing that changed the entire game
is I just sat there and looked at it.
I'm like, look, there's certain things.
By the way, Gabriel Ryan.
Been a minute, bro.
What's up, dude?
Good to have you on.
Gabriel Ryan is in, I think, Nashville, by the way.
Just from my memory.
All right, 2C, baby.
What's up?
Yeah, he was in Oregon, then Vegas, then Nashville.
But anyway, good to see you on, Gabriel.
But yeah, guys, for me, it was just like this idea of
there are certain things in our life we never miss.
We always find a way to sleep.
Whether it's on the airport floor or whether it's in our car.
We always find a way to eat.
We always, well, not always, but typically find a way to shower.
Even if it's like with a baby wipe, you know?
Even if, whatever.
So then I'm like, dude, if I took that exact...
And for me, another thing that wasn't like a necessity,
but I always found myself doing was going and exercising.
And I was like, dude, I'm so dedicated to this.
And that's great.
But like, what if I took this same commitment
where I never miss, I'll wake up at 3 before a vacation
just to make the gym.
Why don't I just take that and turn it
and make it the same with my business and making money?
I said, man, my business, my bank account would sure look a lot more fat.
And that's what I did in 2020.
It was like, if I didn't have a certain amount of closing calls
every single week, I tried to go for one every single day,
which obviously you have to have a lot of things going,
a lot of things moving to get to that point.
But that's it.
It's like, how do we get...
How do we ask somebody for money every single day?
And if we don't, we're not okay.
And that was the whole thing.
And one little hack, I think I shared this...
I can't remember if I shared this on here or on a WhatsApp message.
But guys, a little thing that I did that was so valuable
that helped me so much is in 2020,
I started scheduling a sales call for Saturday morning
at like 6.37 a.m. every single Saturday.
And the reason why I would do it is the business owner,
contrary to what you might think, the business owner actually is...
That's the time they're actually getting stuff done on their business,
not just in their business.
They're usually undistracted.
The other thing is you don't really feel like going out on Friday night
if you know you got a 7 o'clock Saturday morning.
So it caused me to have a really disciplined schedule.
And then lastly is what a better way to start the weekend,
not partying, not going out and getting drunk,
but waking up at 7 a.m. and putting new money,
injecting new money into your business.
So anyway, that was something that really, really changed everything for me.
It made me have a phenomenal weekend, got me excited for Sunday.
I would give myself the rest of the day and Sunday off apart from the planning.
But that was huge is just focusing on
how do you get somebody to give you money?
How do you ask somebody for money every single day?
And if you could figure that out, you're going to make a lot of money
because it's just a numbers game, you know?
It is. Yeah.
That's one of the major things I learned here in this group
is you just have to be hitting up people for money as much as you possibly can.
And then I realized that means having all the inventory.
You know, got to have things moving on the back end to do that.
100%, man. 100%.
So for some, let's talk about somebody that's just starting out
or maybe somebody that's like starting out, meaning there's no deals.
Starting out, meaning, you know, maybe they've gotten distracted
and they found their way back and they're like, hey, this is my year.
I'm really going to give this year my all.
What should they, what are some recommendations of what were,
you know, some things that they should do or not do
from somebody like yourself that started two years ago
and in two years, for those that are just joining,
has scaled up to $87,000 a month, built a software tool
and is on track to absolutely obliterate those numbers this year.
What's your advice for somebody that's brand new?
And while you're doing that, I have got to turn down my heat.
I'm sweating so bad. Keep going.
Yeah, if you're brand new, I still like watch the posts of digital landlords
and see people that post stuff.
If you're brand new to this business model
and you started in the last 30 to 45 days here in the group
or started doing rank and rank in the last 30, 45 days
and you're running ads and you're getting like okay performance,
but not great performance and you're wondering about lead flow
and things like that.
If you're getting momentum in this time of year, that's awesome, right?
Because it's only going to increase going into the spring.
Going into quarter one is when you're going to see leads go like this.
I've seen this happen every year for the last three years now.
Going into the spring, the leads are going to increase.
And so my word of encouragement is if you are just starting this business model
and you're starting in December, you are going to see more momentum
going into the spring, right?
I've seen people post like, hey, what's up with lead flow, whatever.
It's like, well, you've got to think about the psychology
of the people who are picking up the phone.
So the people who are picking up the phone
and the people who need things done largely in home services
is my guess is what you're still teaching in the course, Nick,
is like largely in these high ticket niches.
And high ticket niches means that they're going to spend a lot of money.
And they're thinking right now about spending a lot of money
on Christmas presents, on stuff at the end of the year,
that's the psychology of the American consumer
and homeowner and business owner right now.
Now, business owners may be different
because they're trying to get into the end of the year tax break
and they're putting more into their property or whatever.
But the homeowners, which can make up 80 plus percent of your leads on average,
are thinking about their kids' Christmas,
they're thinking about traveling,
they're thinking about all of these things
that are not related to their property.
And then you go into quarter one and the magic happens.
The magic happens when they're getting tax refunds,
they're getting bonuses from the previous year,
there's cash and capital infusion into a market
and we're also past the election year.
And so despite my growth this year,
I think it could have been even higher
if we were not in an election year
because some of that stuff that Nick talked about
with that squirrely business owner like people aren't buying, I don't know.
I got a lot of that this year.
I think that because we're past that,
there's market confidence regardless of your politics.
It doesn't matter what your political beliefs are.
It's just the decision's been made, yeah.
The decision's been made.
It doesn't matter if you're Democrat or Republican,
none of that matters.
What matters is that we have stability
in the sense of there is someone in the office
and there's going to, every time this happens,
happens every four years,
there's capital infusion back into markets
where money was on the sidelines.
So what happens is, and this is maybe more complex,
but I think this is a point worth bringing in,
is that a lot of the purchasing decisions
for people in this industry
are made by homeowners and property owners
who are always kind of the second money
behind big commercial money,
meaning that a lot of this big commercial money
that's in private equity and commercial properties
and all the growth around those kinds of things
will put money into properties and rental properties
and all that commercial money
that comes back into the market
is generally a good signal
for what's going to happen in the residential market.
And all that money is likely,
because it happens every four years,
going to come back in,
and now that we're past the election year,
we're past the holidays,
and I think you can yell at me if you want to,
but I think next year is going to be
one of the biggest years for this industry
because of these factors at play, right?
We're past the election year.
We're going into a brand new 2025.
There's a lot of money that's been on the sidelines
for the last year that we can all start coming back in
and residential markets are going to follow behind that.
And so I think the pump is primed for 2025.
And so if you're in, if you just started
and you're wondering about lead flow,
think about what time of year it is, okay?
And then realize that next year
we're already primed for potentially
one of the best years in this industry in a while.
There's a noticeable difference.
From right now, December 15th to December 31st,
it can be a bit weird.
By the way, don't think you can't close deals.
By the way, Adair just closed the deal.
Oh, I didn't even say this, by the way.
Shout out to my little brother, Porter, who just hit 10K.
He's been scrapping for 10K, man.
He almost hit it in like a year ago,
and then he got to nine and then he dropped to six.
Then this year he went up to nine, four,
and he's lost three deals.
Some people don't know this.
He lost three deals in a row.
I think he was skipping steps, a little too excited.
And then yesterday I got this call.
I was actually on a sales call with Kyle,
and I got this call and I called him back.
He's like, dude, I finally hit 10K.
So anyway, shout out to you, Porter.
I know you've been scraping your way to get to 10K.
But where was I going with that?
What were we talking about?
Oh, the new year.
And so anyway, there's still deals right now,
but what you're gonna see is from now
till the January 1st can be a little bit weird
with lead flow, with business owners being like,
yeah, I'm taking the time off, whatever.
But even though the weather is the same,
generally speaking, the whole mindset shifts January 1.
It's like business, because think about it, dude.
The business owners you wanna work with,
they're having these exact same conversations.
What are we gonna do?
What's our projections this year?
What are we gonna accomplish?
And as part of that, they need more leads.
And so it's like January 1st,
everyone all of a sudden is like, okay, this is my year.
I see a night and day difference January 1 in the mentality.
Night and day, dude.
Night and day.
Completely night and day.
And I think that there's a trickle over,
and I think it's like either they're looking for it more
or they do see an increase in calls
and interest from their homeowners.
And sometimes holidays are up.
Now let's get the house fixed up.
Let's get everything tidied up.
We're gonna have an amazing year.
Everyone's in this new, fresh.
It's such a good time of year.
So guys, I know some of my Australian people,
it's very weird right now.
What I would recommend for you guys is
if you don't wanna go run ads or whatever
because you're worried that there's not gonna be a lot of leads,
that's fine.
Then spend the next two weeks
finding your next five to 10 areas.
Go and get familiar with Rank and Run Engine,
the due diligence tool on Rank and Run Engine.
And go knock out, the next two weeks,
go knock out 300 due diligence.
And go have your next 15 areas lined out.
Get your ads ready to go.
And January 1, kick those things on.
I'm speaking for Australia because I've got this little,
by the way, if you're from Australia
and you're targeting Australia,
send me a message.
I've got a group chat specifically for Australia
that I'm kind of trying to learn
some of the more nuanced stuff there
that I can add you to.
But a lot of people there have told me
it's a bit weird right now.
But January 1st, everything changes.
So if you're feeling a little weird
or you just joined whatever,
you could still get deals.
But just know everything's about to change January 1st.
So you got two weeks to get yourself prepared.
I definitely wouldn't take my foot off the gas
but just know in two weeks,
things are gonna get Western as Kyle would say.
Kyle by Kyle, yeah, man.
I agree.
I'm gonna use the word night and day difference.
And I couldn't agree more.
It truly is night and day.
Some of these business owners
are already thinking about January,
but they're not actually doing anything yet.
They're waiting to get past the holidays.
January hits and they're thinking like,
how do I grow my business this year more than last year?
And then when you show up as the guy or girl,
it's like, hey, I've got something to take you
to the next level.
They'll listen.
I'm also, I've got, we've had two closing calls this week.
We've got another one tonight at five o'clock.
You can close deals in December.
There's still deals happening in December.
What I'm getting at is if you feel like things are,
the momentum isn't quite where you want it.
It's common is all I'm saying, right?
That momentum is a different speed going into quarter one.
One thing I would recommend to you guys,
I know some of you that just joined,
you guys probably just went through this,
but for anybody that's like,
that doesn't know where to start or kind of,
you know, what should I do?
I definitely think it would be worth you guys
go and check out the video that we did
that you guys are supposed to watch
when you first joined called Exhausted But Satisfied.
Watch that video, set your targets for 2025.
And again, this isn't just financial targets.
This could be any target.
And then reverse engineer and break it up by quarter
and by month and figure out exactly that your roadmap
for how to get to that goal.
And you're gonna realize as you do this,
that the map to get to any goal is really not that difficult.
It can be a straight line.
You make it a zigzag because you get emotional
and you get distracted and all these different things.
But if anyone's looking for like some direction there,
go and rewatch that video.
It's called Exhausted But Satisfied.
And go and set your targets because I know for me,
I have to have that clear map to keep me on track.
And admittedly, this year, I, yeah, this, this,
I even think, I think I posted about this
or I think I did a live about this.
But we, you know, I've made, this year I made more money
than I've ever made, I think.
But it wasn't, because there wasn't like insane growth
like there was, you know, in 2020, for example,
those years always feel better
because you have this, this huge growth.
Even if you make the most amount of money ever,
but you only made slightly more than last year,
it doesn't feel near the same as going from zero to 10
or from 30 to 87.
And so I was, you know, in a lot of ways at my own fault
because I made my road zigzag.
I got distracted by a number of things.
And I, you know, a lot of the stuff I blamed
on personal stuff, which you can't bring into it.
But I'm going back to the drawing board,
back to creating my map,
back to getting even more simple than I am
because I've noticed I've let a lot of stuff creep in
and, you know, it's about subtraction, man.
That's what I've realized.
So guys, we have just a few more minutes.
If anybody has any questions for Ryan,
as we're talking about 2025,
gearing up for the best of your life,
go ahead and drop that in.
If not, I'm gonna go ahead and, in addition, or if not,
I'm gonna go ahead and give away
a little bit of swag ski on this call.
So, by the way, Ryan, do you have the 10K hoodie?
Is that it you're wearing it?
Yeah, bro.
I don't have a 10K hoodie.
Oh, dude, you need the 10K hoodie.
Text me.
I've got the old flat feet mastery hoodie.
I much love speed.
Yeah.
Yeah, money loves speed.
So message me, bro, anyone that's at 10K,
Porter just got his as well.
Well, just message me.
I'll send you the code.
It's completely free and you guys can get it.
So, Ryan, it is cold.
Let's get it before it gets warm again.
Yeah, I want that hoodie.
That's a dope hoodie.
Yeah, dude, it's actually really soft, too.
So it just goes right to your house.
Be there in a few days.
Okay, I want to give, because Adair closed the deal,
I'm gonna give some swag to Adair.
Let's go ahead and swag winner.
Message Ashley for a t-shirt.
All right, I'm gonna go ahead and give him.
And then I gotta hook up some of my,
I got a couple of my friends that are local
that I gotta hook up.
I'm gonna give, I gotta give,
because I see them on the call.
Let's see, I gotta give Mahmood, by the way.
Mahmood, he's been here from the beginning, man.
Mahmood's swag winner.
I know you've been a swag winner before,
but that's okay, I'm gonna give you more.
Message Ashley, I'm gonna give Kevin, my man, Kevin Moss.
Met him in West Africa, of all places.
Go figure.
And Mr. Kudlik as well.
All right, oh, and I gotta give my friend Big Mill, hold on.
All right, let's go right there.
Beautiful.
Okay, so Kevin Moss, message Ashley.
Big Mill Dutton, message Ashley.
Adair, Mahmood, if you won the swag,
just message Ashley, she'll give you a code.
Go to our store at shop, here, I dropped a thing.
DigitalLandlords.com, and she'll give you the code.
You can go right to your house.
It goes right to your house.
So, Ryan Dalton, dude, I appreciate you being on, man.
I know you're super busy.
And once again, guys, if you haven't already,
go jump in, check out Rankin' Ren Engine.
It is, like, with that code, it's like,
with that code, what is it, like, 70 bucks, 80 bucks?
$77, yeah.
It's crazy.
I mean, I don't, not to be that person that's like,
you know, it's one dollar a day,
but it's like two and a half bucks a day.
Run your whole agency.
Keep everything in one place.
So go play around with it.
Even if you guys just do a free account,
to go see how smooth this thing is.
Go start with the free account,
but I would recommend jumping in.
And that's just, that's one of the things
I'm gonna use to scale this year.
So check that out.
There's a code if you scroll up in the chat,
and let's go have the best year of our lives.
Why not?
Yeah, dude, for sure, man.
Yeah, I'm excited about 2025.
I think it's gonna be the best year
in this industry for a lot of us.
For everybody who's doing it,
I think it's just gonna be off the rails.
Like, it is crying for it.
Pretty excited about it.
What's your, let's speak it into existence.
What's your revenue target by next year?
Don't be shy.
By the way, for anyone that thinks
I'm sitting here going,
oh, I don't want Ryan to pass me,
no bigger compliment than Ryan destroying my,
my highest was a 121, I think,
121 to 124 in a month.
It was one month.
We didn't have the systems in place.
We dropped back down.
But I've been like an average hundred.
I hope you obliterate, just so you know.
And that's, I mean that from the bottom of my heart.
So tell me the number now.
Um, I want to be, I want to be at, um,
my, my dream goal,
the one I would push for is 2 million ARR
by the end of 2020.
But I love that.
And that's my goal.
I don't know.
I don't know what that would be for my net.
I mean, yeah, 2 million top line.
Yeah, that'd be a great,
that'd be amazing, bro.
And it totally doable.
I think it can be done.
Yeah, guys.
One of the reasons why being in this group
and in groups like this is important
is just being around people
that have these big visions.
And so I know some of us are sitting there.
Oh my gosh, I got to get to 10K.
And then we've got people like Ryan
that's trying to get to $2 million this year.
So when you find people like Ryan,
keep them close to you.
Yeah.
Love this group.
Love visual landlords.
Learn tons here.
You guys are an awesome community of people.
I made probably lifelong friends in this group.
Nick knows what he's talking about, you guys.
Nick is the greatest resource
in this industry that you could find.
He does a phenomenal job
of making it very relatable and understandable.
And this is where I got started.
I was homegrown first in AOP
and then art of digital real estate now
and then digital landlords.
And there's so much that's possible in this industry.
So thanks to Nick and digital landlords
for having me on these calls
and for this great community of people.
Because honestly like the community
is what one makes it fun to do the business model
because you got people doing it with you.
And you learn from people that are in the group, right?
They try things and they work
and you add it into your agency
and you get better and they get better.
And people that it's not cheap to get in here
to get in this group, to be on this call ain't cheap.
And you'll find that we'll pay for itself over and over
and over again if you dedicate yourself to it.
So thanks Nick for having a great group
here in digital landlords
and for bringing in the best to the content.
Appreciate it, man.
Okay. That said, let's get after it.
Thanks, Ryan.
Cool. See you.